was this something you ever believed in
your lifetime that you could have a
movie career not at all
I had a single to know that Ice Cube
could be good in a movie he was an
intern at the Arsenio Hall Show oh
really yeah I was up there cuz I wanted
to talk to our scene you know because I
wanted him to have you know easy and NWA
on here come John Singleton you know
he's like an intern intern yo you're
cute huh yeah yeah what's up man watch
out what's up you know and he's like yo
man I'm a junior at USC right and you
perfect for my move huh it's like one
your junior USC you don't have a movie
you know these films you're an idiot and
and I'm not even an actor you come talk
about I'm perfect for we all crazy right
oh so everyone associated with this was
not everybody's not what made you do it
well here's what happened you know my
manager tells me one day somebody want
to put you in a movie I have forgot
about this do it of course so I went to
the audition I walk in and it's him
again remember me I'm like damn you know
it's a production now I'm like damn you
it was real you wasn't bullshitting he's
like yeah man I graduated and you
perfect for my movie I auditioned I'm
terrible I mean Isis up right I didn't
read the script I didn't read the sides
I suck and he's worried he's like oh
[ __ ] I'm in chasing a guy who came at
perfect but you can't act so he said
look man did you read my script I said
not in reading I don't read he said look
at you one more shot you go home read my
script and when you come back if you
give you good you're good if not I'm
gonna have to cast somebody else in your
role so I went and read the script and
then you know I had this epiphany like
oh [ __ ] right this is about our
neighborhood this is something I know I
can do yes so when I went back in I took
it serious from then on from that day on
I've been taking filmmaking and
auditioning and acting serious